in Japan there's an art form that by any
standard would be considered extreme
where the paintbrush is made of two
dozen needles and the canvas is human
flesh every inch of flesh from your
wrists to your ankles
it's called hormonal Japanese full-body
tattoo
these full-body masterpieces can cost
tens of thousands of dollars and a
lifetime of suffering to complete I can
feel the needle going in and in and in
but for all that's endured to get one
these tattoos are usually hidden why go
to all that pain and suffering for
something few others will ever see
because showing can identify you as one
of the most notorious and feared members
of Japanese society
they're called Yakuza the gangsters of
Japan they inhabit a world of drug run
prostitution extortion and other crimes
in this realm forum Ono is a mark of
belonging as a result most Japanese view
hormone Oh as a symbol of the mob unfit
for public display but one man is on a
mission to change all that
eg Ruza King is a renowned hormone Oh
master known by the artist name hoary
koi hoary cow uses a time-honored design
that allows wearers to keep their ink
hidden under their clothes
these suits of tattoo are left bare in
strategic places hands feet and center
of the chest
samurai make a fierce showing in many of
these designs most horror Mon oh is
based on legendary warriors and heroes
whose tales have symbolic meaning for
the wearer the images are typically
drawn from classic Japanese woodblock
prints but tattoos weren't always a
matter of personal aesthetics hundreds
of years ago Japanese authorities gave
tattoos to criminals as a form of
punishment these tattoos allowed the
public to identify and ostracize wearers
but by the end of the 17th century
outlaws were hiding these tattoos with
decorative patterns some believe that
the covering of prison tattoos was the
beginning of the notorious link between
organized crime and jaurim oh no hoary
coil eaves that the best way to change
the prejudice against war mono is to
take it on in the flesh once a month he
organizes a performance at a local bar
exposing the public to a mix of karaoke
Japanese tradition and Morimoto by
putting a spotlight on jaurim Ono
Cory Cory hopes to remove the stigma
that has clung to it for so long it
would be very nice to eliminate that
prejudice his efforts may already be
working ever more people are turning to
hoary cow to transform their bodies into
living art this is my life and my style
I hope that people that understand this
join me and I will join them